thick red pepper in the evening is
so really how many folders anyway
parties and so that you start at
franking the organizer for organizing
the night workshop and so my semester
the tank waymarsh and so store problem
from the locations or the senseless or the
easing partition  function
de pees show joint work with han peeters
q is it the university of amsterdam and
de han
er is still wel went through okto rigo 3
houses men working on the scoan and
christensen hannes and export in complex
and emco systems and product hurricane would
make clear  where he is clearly
collaborating your home
okay so see more the partition
functional easing mobile-ready many
times also
quickly the the vision old using this
talk to take a graph die
and by just a woman it's lambda and
rita and me take the partition function  to
be is so about us upsets
the word i put it again now indicate you
the cardinal
fuq and offer the number or ends to that end the
go for you to complement
today is the third  fell parameter and
provides ice creams interaction parameter and
numbers you have to we the de is an
exponential bits up for more and
i come from combinatorics chaz moore
continue to think about it and this work
you so slow full of gerard is qua
here and mortgage the greensight
and  the green bertus is to offer the said
you'd and beautiful skin important thing race
to want to to the tulip power 5 and offers
its orphan 3 number of greenedge here so
be using it already mentioned a lot of
applications and connections to the
herein partition function
they blades people view other things
you so did i mention instagram or
regionally a guy it to story ferme
cut distant magnetism stats or
physics and collect if you set countries
shorten from within the scepter
generating functional the edge coaching
dress raven
and as if he would the runway  short living and
this is so the partition of shirt the uz
teapot modal
women can back to that leather die and
does it too
and she learn recen  tly review flj took the time
wheel
slowly offers it's parents partition
function avowed by output module pro
bilitis there
had to be a customer and service and stuff in
the a list of apps touch it will hear
more about that dissatisfaction and zoom
reasonable forward to that should be
pulled outside is a partition
functions the dark outside lily you
who their
and this is beau jolie provide main focus
of this talk
so modigliani henk kroes is that's your
teen beat from the be real number with their
meines living in living in the
and je fik  state and you look at is
polynomial if the polynomial jolanda ten
under oedsmawei round the unit circle in the
complex play
you will see that 4 more beautiful the many times
and this has led to
en lots full work by many many people
many of a char here two  the site
note whether these people cash registers seemed
2000 citations so that can sign and
mary become it rock to just
je les de most important contributions
such a box won't be of and the pain is
and so my motivatio  n for luke in it is
is is a book so okay who what where the
value zero slider list sam why this
other unit circle met where exactly do
they lie on you met sercom is many of
you know the answer but let me just look
at them  and their special case 2vt pki
short obi-wan in the partition function that
comes again simple living plus la muerte
de power hun hem door curtis is and then
i de rest only one zero wimps meines
one but luckily we without jan de unit
circles and that's fine
with for any other bita think so one
the roots of the polynomials
will actually no bidens under under
units there come
two sometimes and so you check about the
interpolation to nude it or barbie nok
you know we y'all sgp unit circle if
you look at the  klaassen for growth and
this was a motivation to start looking
both example have what we have under
ready they built the green cross can toilets
anti nice product klaassen cross and
the answer when to offer salt s and so
again tell you about
a to  ur arbi dead
after that a couple it was built in
elbers more consequences and den bosch
part of the the torpedo second could phase
of the ride first in the squad of have
discussion connections to the complex
dynamics and then finally out wel eng
cozy and natural open problems that
appear in in doing this work in
particular this gifs points and he is also
a problem is in the field it complex
timings okay without even sun notation
so how you need the app can i left
jibi plus lived collection' or evil or
neck sugi it  mos die plus and on the
notes unit circle with you with your partial
die
and xlii de de open young disc where you
with so my libi level sometimes so
identify circle there intervals with
intervos in in index bye bye english
okay such the first  and who their this is in
the movie the net a case by joy like that
e-ssom
interior fit this interview the enemy
take any he offers in this interval that
man is just about die plus one how we
too access and the tm 6 tank  s is such an
angle titan is your pension offers to
sister with the following holds with eva eva
in in the sir gawaine too many miners that
task to the titan
then there will be no zero is for and
graphics and degree the motif plus one
second part  of this time 6 in the
compliments rio region
de zero is there dance for the claesen
claesen maxims great beautiful that
suddenly she becomes lemon drop picture
vion net incase
the sauerkraut and
to itself even more your circle benny
anyway keep it more like getting rich
bita  here such a garden is a die
meines one that person and then
have my sister microscopic with rick
anyway don't have it
and here
after that roots
and and the complementary region
red hair
human can also knowledge who can affect line
like if you all  images people in that
park tourism will there density of the
roots here is independently test at
gio-goi and rather than people in complex
and mx in they looked at
it and limiting the hague hour of the
bottom and the limiting measu  re of the
zeroes
in in this part in this web part here and
i have a fat you description of
time and libie also mentioned art and so
for that je chair and tree restricted to
the right there when that plus commute
electrical let be okay  the part of
these who is as heavy as a pro bye bye
she is between [ __ ] at data and mark
ghetty and consult only bang and er forgot
to cool down the years we de think it's
about twenty years i ended over
okay so she by you will  be continued
with net incase and a wise
complement prepare the ar formulas for the story
for the kift mtu i would drag
the mangle the torque is how will be fiddle
know the journey the formulas and he
blocks and dynamical systems to
print partitions of the stig  peppers
so you know him flight your death has
a store the form and archives that are
chef to recall wooden door item and you
can do that any day of the week review
is that provide
and so this elevator offers to grate the
too near min  uut and then is title peter
wilco seems is
and and for go this way of offers ado
tough
so and so ends the lee yang 4
and so who has here is already so privacy
rose and well so
of course in the complement what is disco
clerk the good understanding and list
on this klaassen evil so next a bit
like to go to de and the firm it to
the case for even though i don't have
liam 4 to wage war
general length hun der weekend gradually
score becomes have a son  bound i micra
sweat and so who have similar
description and then sorry take the and
we nou has epica in one and now i take
the west crocodile goal of this number here
and then i and through in christ om english
chat in in site is only for  need
serious and xlii bit more storax leafy
take to come for the study curb profit
and to die in a tough call girl oh
seriously
and secondly if you look from the soul
rose in the complementary jori gmail app
germs suffered for those stubai repins
to the under  sir come through the
descript  ion is sleet and its the
term down queso him something to what
know here in
kenwood chef so click here
now we have 11a who learn zero here
and oil has account to the sting his
insight the cage
dergneau soulless by this his
and zoom how  hard it really close to to
the spines
here here how your aim pet iroh's
son love that sit maximal sector this
weekend get
te who are we give roboned i want and
die plus one max and the
greengrass okay and she let me quickly and go made up
any  resnick applications
and at the third the bar shock
philosophy jews interpolation was out
here who can get enough of this with
one
and george is ni zoe for fix landa and
offers thousand stars ruben clients in
the previous team there per se the saizeriya
in the green region  a car with i
rather get and efficient old members toe
approximate with partition function to that
's why you get the green cross and romance
into the beatles be further
word with it in lord of time to be ha  ppy
to it is also offline about
and lemmetjes the latest your son louis
you will build a proxy measurement is
partition functions
when they have a randomized approximation
algorithm to have in the firmware the case
mainly offers 20 euros and live and
countries positive
there are really not like  a lambda sequel
to one and wii home
insight it's interval wimps youtube
ls there sinclair peonies smart was stable
for the this van lambik just
list all sorts of things with it it too tanks
will such a deed paperwhite oh it's beautiful
limburg click on reverse  ice ever to
a new hotel near how girl nessy
neighborhood and the
do you think helicase anyways for the landas
i was so long this section overflow with
as if i want big corsica no longer to be
complex is you take along in that could
live we der z der ze  this small disco
won't be taken to one where there is no
she wrote and then we can al so very
app roksem an we so never keep clear
and jack i so read again to to to this
wie zal
and of course ssp as mentioned in the
stick in the winch and region
insight here where you like seventh fish and
the eyelids and old get back in in
indiana or the to go get back so him
when natural tassels that there ice and found
is the name  it seems the focus on such a
trial would hew how do you taste is what
is the philosophy behind' is and will be is
the international face angle
that tabitha how do i get is she the first
step in the trial and pulled
it off herself  partition functions we need
our tourguide grace joseph partition
functions and in the neck thing is the
express the region and they international of
knowledge
rational functional priory shows on
narrow graff
leading to think of integration of
there than leading to dynamical systems and
hands-on enters  the picture casino they fate
about them and ecosystem
it you black people with the sea
appreciation was like a use mouse to to
to proof this who will om so so could jack
you for the in the penis polynomial did
there is a strip
underw  js on pressure white cabbage and there how
it shiriri and we there she lives in
eating out about
okay so letters titan french form tv shows
so know the partition function and
economy split is in
into two parts to samsung one but your
sam over to success  you were some big fix
pertex
who is insight
and the other by another voice it
becomes gloomy again videos home to the
outside
and stuff because then say he can so the
white by outside and then
and he comes is my way show headset party
at  adwords that
and he is so beautiful because i still have the
situation that top fermentation in
cuzco
something 0 going to be a problem with being
able to equal in technique and the idea
that your weaknesses called other village such a
defined region and you know i just
try  once teak interpretation to this
river beat and long there positive
message calls it complex who lives
he don't want to give an interpretation
and that becomes weak and in itself is that the
partition function is nautique must have
zero
inventory  ft a facial is not equal
to my rhinoceros so led sissies do or
the implications and then are they fits is
region how that i people to mine is one
there is how the less and
reveille meines live sequel to this
excess and multiglide at it is
sure youi cold is i um eine you see in
that of adam and gece rolls-royce
you can invoice something like this via the tiber
we know it from the mentor property of the
way and shows and
and briefly imac knowing the possibility
so above 10 seconds teaser  cirrhosis
with led and also where you build it so
has to transform te problem of
showing that the partition function is a
nonsense euro
to try to show that racial wilmot it
minors what you see this is your doctor in
to salt for first so'  n who in minhstad
have in so the dual is comes a vertex 3
ah yes yes sorry systemfix through those two
yes okay so je transvorm tis with problem
by family me what region is it so a
group seemed more than yards should she go to
the parents  to do more things e  n de
neck step is to try to analyze drivers
tom and very special class of two is you
take the kaylee dries and ludo find an
innocent and
and then the step to will be to thank you
here you can do it for kaylee sad
and weekend we  to do more then release
and finally will use something they even
about power cloud
2 to transform the problem of and eager
to
freeze problem barbie conditions
and will you be in business so
same for the war i was already
suitcase with leslie and belongs too  she
lives his buddy duration
well who will be the focus under first app
fun the most beautiful the complex dynamics'
happening
okay so the de kaylee 3 such
he cerebral hemorrhage and ipads
those heads or or the trio bon level one
viewer level
and die and get  my my my tree of level
looked and and no no go down
she will be you see you just have to us down
the growth there every step and lift that
arabic okay and then weekend doe is
a can try to to to to analyze there what
is is wish for this  tree of level watched
how on purpose did and trams of gray shows
of the tories and level consort is just
his two simple committees with him so
can cloud to riches to give you an
idea
both want to understand tv show in this
level
zodus ratio des artique wimps  i need to
see who one about you
see who loves there is one is 5x so
word texts that in dandy's heads home
to be independent so der noot then they
can draw weekends are product
that are icing about working with trees
like your screen product and  if i have a
power axel in it
so just have to worry about each of any
of the neighbors
and so it more like a leads ikea cosyn
flower and then a jig and swing and so
hear me now and antique a miner vogue
so i it something to  the power that
twice effect orlanda for this word angry
being in would t perfector in front and
and here and now we have
see tea cake liners cheek and i an icare
split into word and two legs vertically
bing out why some how you go bios
notation it who is to math the nuts
blood
and of course and count mistake airco
said he can just add the sting
don't matter something about his coefficient so
is of this one is in and here minus he
drank third factor offers apricot did
it if  this one is in and this one is old
he has there effect orbital here and
simpler right perfect romika for
this one
are an almost at this expression when
the oil caught well has to do is there the
right everything at the sting
then there is the cheek  here were bita
i had an experience from keeps has
in keeps you have to is the region here
no i know in with cars bita tanks
and racial over der ent
okay so that's was still are you
selling these are the many ilustrator of
how you to  the sting
they were snapped fine fashion of the
external complex playing to the external
complex frame
just the functional bit sorry for
if a friend over the occupational health and safety law offers you
the power that and then i give him pain
cellphones did
hee  ft is observations router michonne
runs be able to mine is one what arguing
is that the
partition functions note i need the
corsair and i3 and etc inventory has
we starcatcher operation so function f
could you start me much here live i
so hit miners form  do you
always lose with such an old puzzling
zoë the like us cheeks and the you have to c5
from the sweetheart my minecraft but my
party hobby in about old and the will be
lambda about what we those five plugin argus
when are
you also said you  already over is it
very different one by one plus vita you can
over offers a plus wall signs neighbor that
's how my compliments start the intro
don't be afraid and die start
slowly any questions about is
no reed okay that's how it transformed a
problem in  well then the problem or something
rating this particular function will there be
so c becomes f properties teacher
function house
smart flip her to wide fs long
to time sam functioned hydropower so
and so is of course this function and
je  medical that stretch i already sew them if
which a focus on the case orbita
is leicester won then be able to focus
to under firm third time is the and
the firm i to the case is everything
slightly bit more complicated and will
you report on dysfunction this  is a
möbius transformation
and the perth the in theory or the the unit
circle and that and is exterior and porch
you just like users the unit
circle once use this when i slept
the liam 4 tasted him for trees
shard and eyes byproduct the second
attempt  the for channel graff using this
become many conclusions such and you and so
react is möbius transformation and
al so ff is an orientation preserving
me so perth orientation to the circle
so that she could fini a tincture house and
finally and from computertips derivatives
and je  can espresso derivative seth f
prime article the avatar times
this region and what can you can op service
you look at is region the dvd that absolutely
do you or the the 340 den this is my
brain is of course  frame starting it
and enumerations tardis about me but unit
circle so than ever for easy no to the
unit circuses deadpool beets one end
and so so so tinguely minimize the
fight e-car equal to be worn
was then this region wanted to nominate
mobimex grandma has in  the seasons are
stark moving deliver for
van living then this will the cone smaller
and hence too expensive goes very much
be-combi be so let's keep that in mind
well he don't
tell you little bit about complex
dynamics locally level to b
businesswomen ready to
is the definition you put the photo in in their
villages those sissies quickly remind you
rock lee becomes it is if i have map
that you for everyone knows the photos
and so is itself points which should
for something more at points of loves a
behavior  pon iteration
he boy te getting to to to my
technical that part we that she would
see you check fit and then sorry real fun
to z and then the complement or a key
aedescode giulia set
and alert thing that is  important is that
and fixpoint of mind map
so ff article already such a fixpoint
you scroll attracting has the the river
t of apps of value with less just this
score per bulb i dared tsi
motor absolutely with the weather continue it
yourself  is igor access and it score for
poll has the absolutely do you need
it back now and he is missing and apps
model you are here ist wirklich bigger
than worm
anyway know settings that you're
interested in the your site and clue
interactions of these maps  you have to buy an
existing species and raise a tear it
in in complex en so hats
to montel bulls and the chelsea you there
the julia set we already have more content in
a unit circle
reason for that it is f maps that have a
theory and  theories and that exterior 3
experience to keep and montel bull and
tell you that have you ever been there finite
setpoints ten are you you you can only
be
jefte that you normal family somehow you must
see crime that you cono mi again
bra  vioral millions of jerk to one is
basic who such a moment still so basic but
classical result in in complex
dynamics' the lift points correctly the
bathroom fatou component scan you
most intense so for types
and surprise week in the dark two
options
and so what fresh to  full for the julia set
orders since comes 120 unit circles
leader who in taille unique circle by
notes
she lesson on his sweat minutes that
easy and if it's not the entire units
nice to have the en this implies the photos
are is a single component and
and with the classification of photosets
it is a patch to polish is a
single component and one day a unique
fixpoint woodside expecting or by boat
I that is it so outings to draw
she is the black box and
and this fixpoint hezbollah you under
under
circle knowing glad to die in teri yaad i
was he stayed jonnie and theories is the
Zeeland behavior on the ex who weather then
you become has then fix porns
now how do i check the june is ok so
i  s the black box information
so well he wound about to being you
interprétation of of these numbers hier
hi can go to the river thames en he
look at the wisdom in their value to give
the future value add one s week
sorry for en he computer de  valley
becomes when he lives the simonis is the
wizard i briefly live with you and this
happens i said clean
it the de value pieterbie home the
miners such about deep le soir
we wish you can just computer had we
shaft the theme become a friend
okay  so domino the this is were the white
fish is one and and what you can do is on
you bid a smaller
you see the duration of the foil bigger
than one so your neck offers and bitter and
the takes a while narrower than one to
some how in this case whole incident de
there cannot be and here attracting fix
points of role i find points under unit
circle because you will always be
stöckli do better than you should least at
and julia scenes die a tough unit
circle okay and what week in  conclusion that
exercise is that
this situation de collection' of
programs Islam there for something meines
one is content in your ear bent of this
issue point-one is home to be dance
in the in the unit circle and then
conclude whether that is it who is
rising  interval
den de zeeuw angry of the lies porn
mails ardense order the units come
train quickly give you and knowledge and dr
remove the lamai beach room
no
so takes om it beautiful but unit circle
here reigns my starting point of
and so this is my my  dynamic plain
and here him and doing my my my dynamics'
and he sometimes looked around sometimes a symbol and
those and signs and narrow
take how drone slowly so this is my
mile end a plane
and him so beautiful drawing urine those countries
live such a  to fill in and the walls and
the toe and he lives so such a feast
interval around this point lambda
neurotic me see what
happens there will be doe is also because when he is
around bouquet the family or maps
per with so wise at this interval of
other  and happens
seymour have a tampon integration of
this family my per micro usb this
so much counter the first app and it allows
you to risk wang and a just gonna
be sending when is his when is min of
interval and the walking to hollywood
me and my  using defect it and the brake
strickly
expanding and gonna be just as morel's
wimps you have to feet so long strictly
bigger than we constant factor
bigger and this one their can do the
game and the game the core and the game and
him can b rex planning and  the sun
gate him week offering the
entire unit circle which means that in
the initial interval the master within
rwanda
should your mother major there what's the name of
meines just so who the needle of
hardcore theory for that i think so
dust
calculus essentially okay time again
now and want to go to and to
understanding this this parameter tita
offers and and so reno so a want to
take my pita in this this critical
have of this critical
die wine is one over die plus ge  live and
so trouble for something he invites
this risk is touran is it come that
then again have the tip narrower than one and is
he start how ring at such a point he
wants to dare eco access for
hyrax in absolute beljon and
and  sometimes engine port and to analyze for
and so de
this with eft wonders content per mole the
fix point
so what was that i and
so far i am
expolinc least out of the f train or arm
so i just have to and that f or already there is
a  picture her son she somehow
santing that how interested in a hope
for you i'm going to moby a matrix square you
why 2 views
luke it's between his 60 still to or
asian himself use of this is truly
claesen's
then you'll get this busy college  and
exchange give you
valuable fixpoint arie van der lee
can realize what should be the landa
such a discussion you here the type
from the environment in soest and i will
not white chinese van solving that
i send creatures
about very something like that in do that  x plus 3 what
is not something in more interesti  ng to see
where the original movie is a following
him on and the sixth the mac fsp roll i
ever direction fixpoint
to round the unit circle inventory is in a
the oil who is more in the the parameter
play insight
it is so interval gentlemen it turns out  your
ace came to see the eyeliner injury and
chair
how we should continue 12 min x and y
for this too jenny details about how
would be mounted islam and he
or someone an oil stick tony or line
change am a week and now use the trial de
tier him for the class or tel kaylee
letter jamie trys
ze blades point and toe wanting so is
my my little 10 thijs bigger than this
capital tidhar here de
he do then i do even parabolic sar
je tracking fixpoint substructure gry
which means that a game de  bank the
unit circle is able to offer a game
that it at julia set end and we know
ken and sometimes and djoez' so this argument
or expansion of
course the probationary period the miners one
economy content and sometimes orbit
eksept i do raise signs  n djoez'
the standard masonry company the use then can
also the other magic which
you can google play and dynamical systems
and murder and
so this is dynamical systems tones and
dark users the
know analysis the three show is to
decaliter iso and we know from the  voice
becomes have a star
the neck step is to extend oldies you will
freeze to death bambi conditions and wine
wie conditioner seeds min en count
your shirt inverters so hilts wie
insight my set your again out
of my said you in the selection of this
partition function  and they become you do
so for general 3 cfc the neighbors and
each of these neighbors he reproached
shofar house to ride the end and the
region of me my new 3 will just
be
so multi varies function of the
version of the function the three  just so
before and
so in order to so will you with your son the
slapping we mark
million ready taste the density of the
zeroes here anyways limits proof that
there's no very angry
for this and i found it  the queen evil
both young who has the trial jorinus
now and in order to bloom we see
friends is so beautiful for the start in
devotion
my mind and emco system and want to make
sure they don't get mine is just and
then when they the  best is yet monastery
minors because those de you do video know
what happens
anyway someone averaging weatherby
kicks in and millions were kees
juni and here yes living and lord your house
hows you and this is the the track 10x point
and then you can show  is that is
interval
so beam have insight this self at so
at dysfunction and little f okay that's
good news
and now i want to add to extend to this
multi barrier function
eksept at enter every job how to
conditioners around hair is between so before
them  pushing his steering wheel zero and infinity'
we we have something unusual in about old
and has is your fault is is now
imagine in delhi liberation from over
is over sea sequined infinity and
gather round the somehow is a blue
even the deal or sta  rting your education
at
infiniti red yellow and of course m170
find that there still container here
bright is
equally here and anyway is mi-mi sign
come
free this so interval and that it must
you have that and admit it yourself and who proof
that actually so  conus being sucked
into itself by this universal of the
function
good quality white fork and then but
and who cares it's so king wouldn't
have his back licom ranges domain and
something like that worry easy to see that actually
if it's multiverse function help and
care too  come in moby becomes
invariant under shelter
enhance when starting with the bumbly
conditions are all content in the king
you have to mean it so so capital and
will
map the internet itself mine is living snot there
will be a tin can so again have that
and in a  final step when i slept and
bleed something about braas who has the
use bytes about nutrition becomes retweets
presley shows for grabs
en zo regions of 2 de channel sabi dan
again study you are be c  areful at the come
up with who join mary lou went
gio the bee serious in the
thriller pray him go with a park of
that is also just sports junk
so disc a klutz a test sketch or the
turn arrow
with to the case that andy  foreman at
cases to the similar but the sometimes
don't nag so a little bit your friend there is
an amino latest final 5 minutes to
share some questions an open problems
which you and the first one region aids
van piercing stick en review number
dress sign is between  so interval that
man is 3 plus of that plus of over
the miners of ducks the landa
projective that came tico access
then they showed this an open region the
content is interval for which the
partition function is note ii cuzco for
en ibi time with this  region and for any
body to grab the natural question is
what is the maximal domain for which this
with holes
nu effect
week en show dat voor shirt en
trees pauli commission's you access
class heroes approac  hung close to a
waypoint
and they upload see this by bigpoint and there
is actually my circle which these two
things
become wimps center this is the real
the real time which these powerpoint and
xlii om senseless and the products circo
we want this clothes become the circle is
actually maximum domain for
rides you become sheriff and you a with bacon
new button with it must become clothes
what is the right answer and your be
interesting to see more than to be
second question
and so who knows the partition
functioned pats model he would have the
fine  mr s4 zoom everywhere king
for the turn once a review keyboard
be out offers you the numbers monogamous
labels
and stuff in the easing more games wii rough
racing the number of
on one is neatly over
again waiting offers the number on a
city  color neat but this is too simple
transformation
by aleutian cee'd from the partition
function on the easy model is just the
partition frank snap tattoo stitch plots
model with a sligh  tly different
parameters and and so going back to this
to the statement where that man is one
about that place wang
natural passionateists craze is the acider
is a region at content that interval
die plus one-liners looked over that plus
one comma man is it already there those  time in
so in this region and any graph the
partition function of the spot narrow is
notion room and in particular of you make
a large enough and the see before loose
comes a zero and you love domain of
counting the number record is and they if
these  words you have en efficient
algorithm for accounting the number of
three plus model topless
becomes the police to go rings of er die
plus one er some graff so this is a
feast for one minus one analysis question
to settle
anyhow after the optimist ik in life
address
and just oil market together with
fans un en vws patel
the sheets here and youness here
fresse' record your taste
sum interval excepted who really matters what
you attract notsub times here becomes how you
pull between  the are sleepy about
about your there is the busy the natural
low middle sun's queens right
direction bruno turgot
another open lobes and which xlii
journey is
frome the and tiefer with nets kees and so
he is is exchange for people and the file
were able to screen it son porn turbo be
visible fixed extension looked great
such here in the and so in the in the movie
with nets case where your tits and her
tits and a the and deeper inside but
i just float once alpha and the
minors  eleven packs of meines
and there even the titan and the miners
titan and and so that would be one that there is
here so hard the plums the weight
there is the juniper bulbs fixpoint so
the stones
by that chair bangui charlotte's one and
so can be shown  with chang at at
far and wishes filter tube and lorenzo
bernini and han peeters is that here
between this the street requirements game de
jeroen expect roots
her untergang te prayens around the
ears look around the circle there is not
clear what happens  between pita and oh
fine and so is 11 o'clock there is women to how
far you known went the sector we
so must become clear the third the very
was come to bidens
between a looks and about that anyway
show that it is an office  set to
meaningless and so a preliminary result
shows that there is an interval which may
the dance dance and 10 then wanted
so they have an interesting open question
whether ilates to go go into the complex
dynamics in your tail and swearing just the
food rating  or these maps app what do you mean ben
tower the foundation and combinations or
teacher that day no one easy stuff
okay mentioned is a fine linen final
open problem
yes anyway is back to the two the
computational issue so for the
with more focus is to the carl mcnair the
case
anyway this in the green region thousands of
fishing at every we do we invited
roots ardense here so natural gray
chinese of course m&o hard ze to to a
proximité de partition function in in in
in this part en she  n looking to is
leslie and and level to maybe you guys
can can sort is with him
eijsink dave and the the little tech
star who in your santing industry world the
ever santing here ever and having said
that and we like to thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
engineering you work so thanks
i carry and take a design liter a
week is fine
the room and give you or in some a comb
and brush and i you and you play this
way it's not easy i do with rds to do so
my first my drivers apple has
you the look at the is the regular trees
tile tell you something and sometimes
i has the feel and his son thames
and give never before jump alone in the
first aid there was so so so cardio i
picture to the of  the screen and of you
remember
and by the ratio pores sector exclusion
was insider carrillo it in the game xlii
of the construction and like you were
suggesting it's never fun
who know how to get to zero' is who fun
billion the player hemorrhoids to ra  ting
my look and at composition sophie's
dynamical systems and start it rating
them and nancy cammie plough take that is
up major miners van der noot
may the weekend at some point gymnastics
samsung candide engineering time
boosting the and downs of left
instead of freedom little wild  not
normal region
videos are a british in proportion
he finds he caught he sinks so if
you all a pose choose well guys
did you be
so and the proportion he do know
you siri davinchi 4 you if you
haven't who where your version  fnv road and
andy ferroviaire ont euro he caught the
hot choco is who brain can or
invariant region become you score
invariant
and he single i can make begin wist
semi region in angry angry settings of
course billion retake te de narrower
more f de be careful wooden
mixt a threat santing could be set for a
combination non ferrous and that ferrous
sorry
the seventh reduces and can they
we also went to reproduce the expensive
products r  ennes and trad had to do so
for a sad third the limits
the studios in the house are completely
computer to stop the some extent so much
random regular
and out so double concert star in van it
became anyway you have to bacon may
business similar behavior company
show dare  to to to say the out of my
clearing there kind and of which
nice and angelique number
led study that surya reference to
his interest
that is a good point
if so how the real counter is the singer
pepper at the d d d d but who if
improve this me such a  barry be
the look out this is your pass know
where this is lyn met will likely be the
limit of tim fraiture trio no second row
do rtc we go so deep so for my
there a feature
and you kind of bugis garland of cabinet
triologi
if  you like this and travel is the
samblanx determine in a warm water choose
ortega the machinery translator neck through
san marino and house
result er that name is any bieber is
a concept for healing too loud for  your
child
neat we have a photo build time
rakesh mini interpolation here is very
clear she a macho de so also in view
it is can it be a natural perspective
or or look and it is in fact a
year now i have to do
novotel and very rich
hey
[  Music]
[Applause]